antenne de à la une ce soir émotion en
allemagne où les débordements de
violences atteignent des sommets sans
précédent
hier soir deux policiers ont été tués
neuf autres ont été grièvement blessés
le drame s'est déroulé à francfort
arsenal de guerre à bord de l'ectrims
cargo arraisonné en bretagne
transportait des missiles et des
milliers d'armes de fabrication
soviétique sans doute pour l'ira et le
terrorisme international
le recul de l'effet le pen selon un
sondage sofres rtl le monde 78 % des
français rejettent ces idées 8 %
souhaitent accorder leur suffrage au
leader du front national
retardé par la tempête boursière la
cotation de suez débutera lundi
les souscripteurs ferron l'action deux
fois et à un an d'intervalle
une procédure qui pourrait être celle
des prochaines privatisation rentrée
vous ça s'est éteint cette nuit victime
d'un cancer le célèbre auteur de théâtre
avait 76 ans dans ce journal l'hommage
des comédiens marie affiche en ce moment
un classique d'entrée houssin la petite
chatte est mort une journée
supplémentaire de détention pour marcel
carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés dans le sillage
de la sphère lüscher dont on parle
beaucoup en ce moment l'éternel problème
du financement des partis politiques
fait un retour en force à la une de
l'actualité
hier soir sur antenne 2 pierre
méhaignerie parler d'électrochoc pour
tous les partis politiques français
aujourd'hui la plupart des leaders prône
la transparence alors au delà de ces
déclarations il est tout de même permis
de s'interroger pourquoi par exemple
aucun texte de loi n'a été votée alors
que depuis 1924 de nombreuses
propositions étaient déposés sur le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale olivier
lerner et daniel brême ont essayé de
comprendre en compagnie bien sûr
désintéressé une campagne électorale
coûte cher hr et tous les records seront
battus en 81 buts
chaque candidat à l'élection
présidentielle dépensera pour sa
campagne
entre 100 et 150 millions de francs des
budgets faramineux affiche banquet
meeting déplacement pour se faire une
idée
une simple location d'un chapiteau pour
une soirée de 5000 places coûtent
environ 100 mille francs
à cela il faut ajouter vidéo décor sono
dîner gardiennage eds et la pub exemple
le dernier meeting de françois léotard à
fréjus a coûté la bagatelle de 6
millions de francs pour financer une
campagne électorale chacun dispose de
ses propres réseaux cotisations des
sympathisants cotisations des élus mais
en réalité la plus grosse part du budget
des candidats est apportée par des
industriels les plus gros finance tous
les partis des dons en dessous de table
ni vu ni connu du grand public mais fort
appréciée dans les étangs
en politique tout parlementaire qui se
respecte réclame transparence contrôle
plafonnement et l'interdiction de
percevoir des fonds de l'étranger
si une dizaine de propositions de loi
ont déjà été déposées aucun texte n'a à
ce jour été examiné par les députés
et ce n'est pas pour demain je doute que
d'ici l'élection présidentielle nous
ayons matériellement le temps de nous
mettre d'accord à partir de positions
qui sont quand même assez différente et
de faire passer une loi devant
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat fait
des repères depuis maintenant plus de 10
ans qui s'est toujours opposé à
l'inscription de ce genre de projet à
l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée nationale
c'est la raison pour laquelle je le
demande depuis longtemps mais je ne
désespère pas maintenant de l'obtenir
puisque l'europe udf a déposé un projet
de loi et si le groupe edf est fidèle à
sa position qu'ils votent pour
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour avec moi
et bien ce débat aura lieu dans quinze
jours la guerre d'usure entre les
différents partis va donc continuer
c'est le gouvernement et lui seul qui en
fin de compte décidera d'inscrire ou non
le financement des partis à l'ordre du
jour de l'assemblée
affaire à suivre en tout cas et de très
près à francfort la violence des
manifestants atteint des sommets sans
précédent deux policiers ont été tués
hier soit en neuf autres ont été
grièvement blessés le drame s'est
déroulé à l'issue d'une manifestation
écologiste en toile de fond il y a à la
nouvelle piste de l'aéroport de
francfort pendant des années les
écologistes ont multiplié les
manifestations pour s'opposer à la
construction
depuis l'an dernier la piste est
terminée mais les passions sont loin
d'être retombée
patricia cost ces images tournées par un
amateur permettent de comprendre
exactement ce qui s'est passé derrière
le mur de l'aéroport les écolos
pacifistes allemands préparent des
cocktails molotov
attention attention dispersez vous
demande un policier avec un porte-voix
réponse des écolos pacifistes des tirs
nourris de tous côtés
avec toutes sortes de projectiles dont
des armes à feu mais c'est au moment où
les policiers chargeront à pied les
écolos pacifiste pour les déloger du
petit bois où ils se sont retranchés que
deux policiers seront touchés
à mort neuf de leurs collègues seront
grièvement blessé la région est
immédiatement quadriller et un suspect a
été arrêté ce matin en possession d'un
pistolet 9 mm semblable à celui utilisé
lors de la manifestation tragique
anniversaire pour une bataille commencé
il ya sept ans les écologistes alors
beaucoup plus nombreux qu'aujourd'hui
s'étaient réunis autour d'un mot d'ordre
non à la construction d'une nouvelle
piste pour l'aéroport de francfort piste
qui amputait leur art espace vert encore
présents autour de la ville malgré une
pétition rassemblant plus de 200 mille
signatures et réclamant un plébiscite à
ce sujet la piste s'est construite de
tout de même 200 irréductibles sont
revenus hier et pour la première fois
ils ont tué pour la première fois aussi
les policiers bouleversé sont descendus
dans la plupart des grandes villes
d'allemagne la politique avec un nouveau
coup dur pour jean marie le pen alors
qu'il lançait un appel au rassemblement
dans le cadre prestigieux de la baie du
mont saint michel
nos confrères du monde et de rtl publié
un sondage sofres sondage selon lequel
l'audience et les thèses du front
national sont en net recul
78% des français se déclarent hostiles à
jean marie le pen
ils n'étaient que 50 7% en novembre 84
des chiffres qui ne semble pas inquiéter
outre mesure l'état major du front
national où l'on se dit plus que jamais
déterminés laurent boussier six mois
après sa déclaration de candidature six
mois avant l'échéance électorale
c'est la mi-temps pour jean marie le pen
une huit ans qu'il aurait voulu loin des
sondages et qui a pris aujourd'hui la
forme d'une déclaration solennelle faite
en un lieu symbolique les remparts du
mont saint michel
tout y était la terre la mer le ciel
saint michel le patron des parachutistes
et même jeanne d'arc la valeur de
référence du front national jean marie
le pen s'en est pris une fois de plus
aux partis politiques traditionnels à
l'insécurité au laxisme au sida et à
l'état qui je cite écrase le pays sous
son poids après avoir annoncé que pour
la deuxième partie de sa campagne il
allait passer la vitesse supérieure
le président du front national a
commenté le sondage rtl le monde qui lui
donne lui % d'intentions de vote au
premier tour des prochaines élections
moi je n'ai pas d'argent à consacrer aux
sandales et je me sente dans les yeux
des gens que je rencontre et ce que je
vois depuis plusieurs semaines le fait
que j'ai reçu deux démissions de mer et
que j'en ai eu 27 nouvelles que nous
avons et des centaines d'adhérents et
seulement trois démissions tout ceci me
semble aller dans le sens au contraire
d'un renforcement et pourtant 8%
d'intentions de vote c'est un point de
moins que le même sondage l'été dernier
suite et fin du voyage de monsieur
jacques chirac en israël en deux jours
et demi le premier ministre a non
seulement consolider les liens entre
paris et tel aviv
mais il a surtout sceller les
retrouvailles entre le mouvement
gaulliste et jérusalem sur place à
l'heure des bilans
georges bortoli monsieur chirac a reçu
cet après midi plusieurs personnalités
palestiniennes des territoires occupés
ces rencontres entre officiels français
et palestinien étant désormais trop
habituel pour entamer une confiance
retrouvée entre paris et israël ce
voyage a participé comme beaucoup
d'autres qui se sont multipliés
depuis quelque temps à dissiper un
certain nombre de malentendus
traditionnelle qui provoquait parfois
quelques crispations dans les relations
entre la france et israël
mais c'est chirac a constaté que la cote
de la france note en israël ce voyage
évidemment a contribué à ce qu'elle
continue à monter sans que pour autant
soit abandonné les positions
traditionnelles de la france vis-à-vis
du monde arabe
à tahiti nouvelles inculpations après
les émeutes du 23 octobre dernier après
l'arrestation du président et du
vice-président du syndicat des dockers
le président des gens de mer léon lenoir
a été écroué à son tour pour dégradation
par substance explosive et incendiaires
au total 53 personnes ont été écrouées
dans le cadre des émeutes de papeete
aujourd'hui l'état d'urgence est
maintenu mais l'arrêté de fermeture des
bars et des boîtes de nuits a été levé
il n'empêche qu'à tahiti on est toujours
dans l'expectative certains craignent
même le déclenchement d'une grève
générale dans les jours qui viennent
d'autres parlent de situation tendue
mais ajoute que le phénomène n'est pas
réellement nouveau ce discours c'est
celui des communautés religieuses
communauté dont l'influent ce n'a jamais
été aussi grande et aussi forte
dominique pierre pour rien au monde
les tahitiens n'aurait manqué cette fête
religieuse l'atout lama va la nuit ou
non envahi de lumière les cimetières de
la ville et pour que chacun puisse à
célébrer en toute liberté
le haut commissariat avait suspendu le
couvre-feu tact diplomatie mesures
d'apaisement
quelles que soient les justificatifs le
fait est là l'administration ménages
l'église et pour cause l'église ou
plutôt les églises pèse lourdement sur
toute la vie politique et sociale du
pays
au milieu d'une trentaine de personnes
michel coppenrath l'évêque de tahiti un
presque polynésiens né d'une mère
européenne et d'un père tahitien un
homme dont on dit ici que rien ne se
fait sans lui hommes politiques de tous
bords syndicalistes il reçoit écoute
conseille l'église catholique touche
essentiellement la population européenne
et chinoise
les polynésiens eux sont à 90%
protestants il ya près de deux siècles
30 missionnaire anglais poser le pied
sur cette plage à 20km de papeete où
jenny des prédicateurs il traduisait la
bible en tahitien est encore aujourd'hui
de nombreux enfants apprennent à lire
dans ce livre avec 80 ans pelé près de
90 mille fidèles l'église protestante
est la première du territoire et elle ne
mâche pas ses mots lorsqu'elle condamne
les essais nucléaires de mururoa
lorsqu'elle dénonce la politique
foncière du gouvernement territorial
mais elle ne craint pas de paraître
engagé
il n'y a pas de domaine de
pour l'église n'aurait pas de rôle à
jouer là où elle vit l'église quelque
chose à dire un certain nombre de
vérités à transmettre
il ya ensuite à l'autre la pêche qui est
touché par ce sauvetage à mettre en
application le vécu du message se
voulant plus discrète sur la scène
publique
l'église catholique n'a pourtant pas
hésité à jouer l'an dernier les
intermédiaires entre le gouvernement
territorial et déjà le syndicat des
dockers
c'est elle qui a tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé c'est elle qui a dénoncé les
criantes inégalités sociales du
territoire un sévère rappel à l'ordre
actuellement il faut être accepté d'être
impopulaire et je voudrais bien que des
hommes politiques et même des dépenses
de certains syndicats acceptent de dire
courageusement les choses qu'on ne peut
faire et qu'on ne peut pas faire c'est
fini le climat d'insouciance dans lequel
nous vivons et de l'insouciance nous
avons passé au feu
dans les semaines qui viennent les
autorités catholiques et protestantes
tenteront de débloquer la situation de
rétablir le dialogue entre les hommes
politiques et les syndicats afin
d'éviter que chacun durci ses positions
demain nouveau dossier pour vous
permettre de mieux appréhender la
situation à tahiti nous parlerons
longuement d'économistes voyons
rapidement les télégrammes de l'étranger
ensuite nous évoquerons une nouvelle
fois les fluctuations du dollar
probable démission dans la semaine de
caspar weinberger le secrétaire
américain à la défense sa décision
serait essentiellement motivée par la
détérioration de l'état de santé de son
épouse âgée de 70 ans de shiwan burger
et depuis sept ans dans le gouvernement
du président reagan
il pourrait être remplacé par frank
carlucci l'actuel conseiller de la
maison blanche pour la sécurité
new york les ambassadeurs d'iran et
d'irak ont remis hier soir leur réponse
au plan de paix proposé par l'onu dans
le conflit qui oppose les deux pays
ses réponses sont pour l'instant
secrètes les deux protagonistes s'est on
borné à qualifier leurs contenus de
positif si la proposition de monsieur
perez de cuellar en neuf points
s'articule autour d'un jour j de
cessez-le-feu dont la date reste à fixer
explosion d'une voiture piégée ce matin
au koweït à proximité du ministère de
l'intérieur l'attentât n'a pas fait de
victime
c'est le huitième depuis le début de
l'année une agence de voyage avaient
ainsi été endommagés il ya quinze jours
la presse koweïtienne avait alors accusé
l'iran
le ministre de la défense andré giraud
assisté cet après midi aux obsèques des
deux gendarmes assassiné la semaine
dernière à beyrouth
la cérémonie s'est déroulée à dijon où
il était basé le lieutenant mondon et
l'a vu dans cruz ont été décoré à titre
posthume
retour en france en commençant par une
information pratique lavignotte 88 que
voici est en vente depuis ce matin vous
savez que le prix de la vignette varie
selon les départements
prenons la référence d'un véhicule de
cinq à sept chevaux de moins de cinq ans
le tarif le plus haut est pratiqué dans
le département du rhône 466 francs
exactement le tarif le plus bas dans le
calvados avec 374 francs autre
information importante pour les 1
million 600 mille personnes qui ont
acheté les actions du groupe suez le
ministère des finances qui avait
repoussé l'introduction en bourse en
raison de la forte baisse des marchés
financiers annonce que cette
introduction aura finalement lieu lundi
prochain le 9
introduction assortie d'une petite fleur
les souscripteurs pourront payer leur
action en deux fois
patrick boitet les privatisations
continue mais à crédit les 1 million 600
mille français acquéreur de suez à 317
francs l'action régleront leurs titres
en deux fois la première moitié le 18
novembre prochain
le reste un an plus tard si entre temps
les souscripteurs décide de vendre leurs
actions ils devront régler la seconde
moitié du titre
ces facilités de paiement
n'interviendront en rien sur les
conditions d'attribution des actions
gratuites
le gouvernement a pris cette décision
après avis de la commission de la
privatisation c'est un moyen pense punch
et edouard balladur de fidéliser les
souscripteurs l'action suez risque en
effet d'être chahuté lors de sa cotation
le 9 novembre prochain en raison de la
forte baisse des marchés financiers la
cote officieux sur le marché gris de
londres a déjà chuté jusqu'à 270 francs
pour l'état
le monte gagné cette année 2,9 milliards
et demi une somme qui sera récupérée en
a part ça le dollar a connu un vif recul
aujourd'hui contre le marquis il est
tombé à son plus bas niveau historique
aujourd'hui à francfort le dollar ne
cotait plus qu'un marc 70 50
il est tombé un peu plus bas encore à
new york ce mouvement du billet vert a
de nouveau secoué vous en douter les
marchés financiers suite logique des
événements ou nouveau coup de torchon
philippe sassier c'est la question que
je vous pose ce soir écoutez le fort
recul de wall street qui perdait il ya
une heure plus de 120 points qui a
remonté depuis montre que les langes et
ne se sont pas évanouies la partie de
bras de fer entre américains et
allemands continuent aujourd'hui
contrairement
aux espoirs l'allemagne a refusé de
baisser ses taux d'intérêt tandis que le
japon critiques de plus en plus
ouvertement le déficit budgétaire
américain dont on fait la tête de turc
de cette crise en oubliant qu'il a été
le moteur de l'économie mondiale du coup
on voit mal comment pourrait se tenir
cette conférence internationale si
attendue est destinée à travers des
engagements précis à renforcer la
coopération entre les différents pays
sans cet accord la tempête boursière
peut de nouveau se lever l'allemagne et
le japon ce ne sont guère charitable
envers l'oncle sam qui les a aidés à se
relever après la guerre cette révolte
financière des neveux qui ont fait
fortune à l'égard de l'oncle endettés
qui puise un peu cavalièrement c'est
vrai dans leur kerlir aura des
répercussions de politique
internationale
merci 20 missiles sam-7 et plusieurs
milliers de mitraillette kalachnikov ont
été découverts cet après midi à brest à
bord du cargo exxon 2 le cargo panaméen
avait été arraisonné je vous le rappelle
vendredi dernier au large de l'île de
batz en bretagne aujourd'hui
l'interrogatoire des cinq hommes
d'équipage tous de nationalité
irlandaise s'est poursuivie quant à la
police irlandaise plutôt sceptique au
départ elle le prend très au sérieux la
piste de l'ira à brest
reportage de patrice pollet l'arsenal de
brest cet après midi et à kehl exeunt le
bateau panaméen ce qu'elle découvre
l'art mais les douaniers français au fil
des heures au fond des cales du bateau
est de plus en plus impressionnant dans
ses caisses des kalachnikovs par
milliers plusieurs tonnes de but 106 et
puis des centaines de fusils
mitrailleurs
mais ce qu'ont découvert il ya quelques
heures les autorités françaises
dépassent de loin ceux que l'on pouvait
imaginer
en matière de trafic d'armes qui
inquiète le plus les autorités si c'est
ce qu'on a trouvé au fond des cales du
bateau
je veux parler d'une vingtaine de
missiles sam-7 de provenances d'union
soviétique
alors à qui et pourquoi étaient destinés
ces missiles des missiles plus
performant très dangereux que se
partagent dans tous les pays du monde
ceux qui veulent faire la guerre le sam
7 est un missile individuel
d'interception aérienne en france deux
de ces engins ont déjà été découverts
dans une cache de lothaire mais cette
fois ci c'est peut-être alliera qu'ils
étaient destinés tout le laisse penser
dans les milieux de l'ira belle phase ne
déclare-t-on pas aujourd'hui que toutes
ces armes étaient destinées à lutter
contre les troupes d'occupation
britannique en irlande du nord
et puis il ira entretient des relations
avec la libye du colonel kadhafi or le
bateau serait parti de tripoli et le
colonel kadhafi possède bien ce genre
d'armement
si régime on aurait pu être équipé avec
les 150 tonnes d'armes saisie des armes
neuf jamais utilisé depuis samedi les
cinq hommes d'équipage sont interrogé
sans relâche par la police les
passeports volés ont été retrouvés sur
certains d'entre eux des passeports déjà
retrouvé dans une cache de l'ira à
glasgow
cette saisie d'armes et la plus
importante jamais réalisée au monde
le srpj de rennes et la brigade
anti-terroriste travaillent ensemble
pour dénouer le fil de cette
interception d'armes record le monde du
théâtre est en deuil vous l'avez entendu
tout à l'heure en ouverture du journal
andré roussin auteur dramatique et
académicien est décédé cet après midi à
60 18 ans des suites d'un cancer
andré roussin homme de scène et hommes
de verbes personnifier le théâtre jean
jacques dufour drôle de destinée que
celle d'andré roussin qui commence sa
carrière théâtrale dans une entreprise
d'avant-garde pour finalement devenir
l'auteur de boulevard le plus joué de
l'après guerre avec une régularité
d'horloge il collectionne les succès la
petite hutte en 47 qui reste à la fiche
cinq ans lorsque l'enfant paraît les
oeufs de l'autruche bobosse et cetera et
cetera
la liste n'est pas exhaustive plus que
dans les situations
le comique grande rousse un résident
dans le langage même si parfois
apparemment
en somme au boss ça n'est pas votre vrai
nom d'où vient ce surnom
et bien voici lorsque j'étais tout petit
ma nourrice m'a laissé tomber sur la
tête et j'ai eu une énorme bosse alors
je me plaignais souvent dix ans comme
font les enfants boss n'est ce pas et
bobo c'est devenu mon surnom je les
gardais la bosse aussi d'ailleurs vous
pratiquer le yoga à n'ont absolument pas
non mais cette position dans laquelle je
viens de vous trouver
et bien c'est une amie qui m'a affirmé
qu'en faisant l'arbre droits sur ma
bosse très précisément et en comptant
jusqu'à 102 fois par jour j'arriverai à
la faire disparaître complètement à la
résorber pour andré roussin les choses
furent facile il déclaré j'écris sans
penser à rien petit à petit cela devient
une pièce quelle chance la chance c'est
que ce qui m'a amusé quand j'écrivais
une pièce amusé ensuite le public quand
on la lui je sais ça la chance parce que
je pourrais être tout seul à rire et
ensuite que ça ne plaise pas il se
trouve que ce qui m'a amusé ou qui m'a
plu ou qui m'a touché la preuve des
réservations est là pour montrer que les
autres qui ont été sensibles où sont
amusés de la même façon c'est la chance
et c'est le succès dans la lignée de
feydeau et de sacha guitry roussin
réussi à faire du boulevard sans jamais
tomber dans le caniveau
il avait trop de tendresse et de
fraîcheur pour cela oui à dire
pourras-tu rang oui parce que tu savais
que des derniers mois le coup ci c'est
depuis que tu es jugé bon d'en faire
autant la dernière pièce d'andré roussin
intitulé la petite chatte est morte se
joue actuellement salle gaveau à paris
où nous attend georges de georges bigot
je suppose que ce soir l'ambiance est à
l'émotion et au recueillement genre eh
oui on est bien triste parce que dans
cette salle gaveau vient de se terminer
la petite chatte est morte à l'instant
et il était là à peine ni à 3-4 jours il
vous rend des visites et jean laurent
cochet je vais vous demander évidemment
la peine personnel que ça vous fait mais
aussi quel homme important de théâtre il
était là personnel bien sûr et que je
partage avec les siens que j'aimais tant
mais je voudrais comme dans tout
événement futile douloureux une marque
le côté lumineux
alors rappelons très vite ce que les
gens n'ont pas toujours su souligner
surtout ces dernières années on lui
faisait payer beaucoup de triomphe qui
avait été le sien toute sa carrière il
le savait et rubliés un peu trop qu'il
était à la suite de molière et des plus
grands avec à nous notre dernier grands
auteurs classiques par la construction
par le contenu de ses oeuvres on le
découvrira petit à petit
et puisque lui même a fait très souvent
dans ces pièces de la mort le personnage
principal il fallait monter ses oeuvres
pour s'en rendre compte de ce one in là
où le mari la femme l'amant 11 et il en
fait un personnage vaudevillesque je
pense que donc il l'est déjà
au delà il a rejoint ce molière sur
lequel il vient d'écrire ces deux pièces
que nous jouons et qui est un
chef-d'oeuvre l'intelligence et l'esprit
qui est injustement dramatique en
hommage au théâtre comédien à molières
donc maintenant en hommage à rousset
alors quand on est comédien dominique
paturel andré roussin s'est humblement
comme il l'était aussi lui comédien oui
il adorait ça c'était un homme qui avait
cette espèce de l'heure dans l'oeil se
fait-il immense était un farceur il
aimait bien à faire de la le faire des
blagues comme ça en écrivant des pièces
drôles et il aimait jouer la comédie il
est il a été son interprète il a joué la
petite hutte il a joué plusieurs pièces
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il avait
cette espèce de dialogue unique qui est
une langue formidable pour les comédiens
il savait de quoi il parlait et il
écrivait des pièces qui a été fait pour
les acteurs il a toujours écrit des
rôles merveilleux pour les acteurs dans
toutes ses pièces c'était vraiment du
théâtre pour les comédiens et du théâtre
tout public et je pense que maintenant
comme toujours un peu en france c'est
après coup qu'on s'apercevra la place
énorme qu'il tenait dans notre théâtre
lorsqu'ils venaient ces jours derniers
on s'attendait à une fin aussi brutale
il était très fatigué depuis quelques
puis quelques mois mais toujours aussi
saignant qu'elle souhaite toujours aussi
aiguë je devais l'appeler demain matin
pour prendre rendez-vous pour qu'il me
lisent un projet une pièce qu'il avait
dans ses tiroirs
donc vous voyez que tout en étant
conscient de son état était quand même
déjà dans l'avenir autrement dit dans
l'éternité
je vous remercie dans la région de gap
bientôt la fin d'un drame le spéléologue
blessés dans le gouffre du dévoluy est
en passe d'être sauvés ce soir sur place
une vingtaine de spéléologues volontaire
des crs et les pompiers sont mobilisés
depuis de longues heures agnès poirier
après 48 heures d'efforts de nij eto'o
vient juste d'être sorti du gouffre du
dévoluy les boyaux du gouffre très
accidenté sur une centaine de mètres ne
permettait pas le passage la civière
trois spéléologues spécialistes des
explosifs ont donc mètre par mètre
dégager la partie la plus étroite
opération délicate l'explosif la titanic
25 devait être dos
et avec précision afin de ne pas
provoquer l'éboulement victime d'une
fracture au bassin ce spéléologue
confirmé de 30 ans devait forcément être
remonté arrimé à une civière
il a été transporté ce soir par
hélicoptère à l'hôpital de gap jean ma
mère le tennis on joue à bercy en ce
moment je raccroche de téléphone noah
joue ce soir tel événement il ya eu des
résultats intéressants cette après midi
vous y avez gagné rapidement
un résultat logique celui de pat cash
qui a éliminé paul annacone en deux sets
6-4 6-4 par contre mauvaise après-midi
pour les français thierry tulasne
éliminé par le hollandais schepers un
joueur issu des qualifications en deux
sets 6-3 6-3 et tarik benhabilès battu
par rachid bahrami en deux sets les deux
tie break 7 5 7 7 6 7 6 bahrami qui sera
peut-être le prochain adversaire de
yannick noah
les knicks noah que nous allons
retrouver sur le court central de bercy
au moment du ralenti puisqu'il vient de
remporter son service et il mène
maintenant dans ce premier projet à deux
la partie est commencée depuis
maintenant un petit quart d'heure
personne n'a fait le break pour
l'instant nos âges où le service volée
si son jeu va zur essaye de répondre
comme il peut pour l'instant la partie
est très équilibré on le retrouve ce
soir aux alentours de 11h15 sur un
tender et qu'un résumé de cette
rencontre les six jours de grenoble
cocorico vallée mottez ont gagné dans la
dernière chasse fallait le faire c'est
pas évident oui surtout que vale mottez
était très mal en point la veille face à
dos les deux wild va laisser sa dernière
apparition à grenoble mais pour une
dernière soirée il a mené sur un rythme
d'enfer et de la gagner la partie
je dirais sur le fil et vous allez voir
que l'image n'est pas trop forte car
avant de recevoir ce maillot de
vainqueur et d'effectuer le tour
d'honneur
le duo va les mater a connu quelques
frayeurs et le public a eu droit à un
finish à suspense
le principe des six jours il est simple
en courant par équipe de 2 comme ici
moser bingo lato il faut accomplir le
plus de tours possible de l'anneau de
400 m
si aucune équipe ne parvient à se
détacher ce sont alors les points
attribués qui font la différence
mais lorsqu après six jours c'est
l'égalité totale entre deux formations
il faut rompre
comme pour une course qui seront au
verdict du sprint est ici valais dans
les derniers mètres est à la lutte avec
deux wild et il est le plus rapide sur
la ligne alors le plus rapide c'est un
grand mot car même si la foule est
debout dans lequel vivent ils ne gagnent
que d'une petite feuille par feuille on
attend maintenant les séjours de bercy
la météo elle est synonyme de soleil
jose est toujours bonjour aurait
effectivement toujours un temps calme et
sec mais pour les nuages ne fut rien
vous promettre en effet ils seront peu
nombreux mais se promenant se
promèneront un petit peu au hasard
pourquoi se calmer en raison d'un
anticyclone toujours situés sur les îles
britanniques et qui nous protège de
toute menace de perturbations
donc demain matin après la dissipation
des traditionnels brume et bien place au
soleil avec toutefois donc des passages
nuageux
çà et là surtout sur le nord de la
france sur la moitié nord du vent d'est
qui continuera à souffler de la vendée
au cotentin ainsi que dans le midi
côté température et bien elles vont
chuter un tout petit peu 9° à nancy 13 à
nantes sur la moitié sud 11 à clermont
ferrand et toujours 20 à ajaccio demain
mercredi 4 novembre
pensez aux charles rochet rendez vous
d'information 23h30 avec aubry et de
leurs n'oubliez pas le tennis à bercy
également avec notamment le résultat du
match de yannick noah
demain dès 6h45 télé matin à 7h45 c'est
pierre mauroy qui sera l'invité des 4
vérités présenté par gérard morin
bonsoir excellente soirée sur antenne 2
et à demain